Hi, I'm Mike Snyder I'm looking
forward to telling you about our "New
Frontiers in Cancer Genomics" course. Its an exciting new area that has lots of exciting
things happening and your gonna learn
about them in this course. Cancer is a
really, really important disease. 50% of
man and 33% of women will get
cancer at some point in their lifetime.
We need better ways of diagnosing cancer
and we also very sorely need better
treatments. Cancer is a genetic disease.
Almost all cancers are the results of
multiple mutations. Cancer is also a
genomic disease in that every cancer cell
has a unique collection of changes that
cause cells to grow uncontrollably. If we
really want understanding cancer, and
also treat cancer, we have to look very
carefully at the DNA of their cancer.
What we're gonna learn in this class is the
difference between inherited and
sporadic cancers, or inherited cancers;
the familiar cancers, the kind that run
in families. We're also going to learn
about classifying cancers based on the
genome differences, not just where they
come from. Very importantly, you're going to
understand how cancer cells evolved to
become resistant to treatment. There's a
number of community initiatives for
enhancing cancer research and
understanding how cancer cures. And
finally you're going to hear some very
cool primary research that's occurring
in the cancer field and some of the
exciting developments that are going on.
And certainly you're going to hear about
current challenges in terms of trying to
understand tree and research cancer. So
overall it's going to be an incredibly
exciting chorus. Ah, there's so many new
developments, ah, that you're going to learn about. Can't wait to get started!